Luke isn't slowing down but everyone's
falling down smoker oi
and cam is taking us through the whole
alphabet as I always say ABC always
began this is Hannah Browns season of
The Bachelorette episode two grab your
glasses it's time for roses and rose say
hi you guys i'm lauren zima
I'm here just like a mime everywhere in
every moment of the episode invited or
not but thank you your friend writing me
onto your screens I love you guys so
much what a season this is so far I'm
loving it I think the guys have so much
personality what did you think of
episode two let us know in the comments
below and let's dive right in today I
have my Rose a in a champagne glass for
a couple of reasons one because I just
wanted cheers to Hannah she is wowing me
thus far and two I didn't have any clean
wine glasses so you got you got to drink
more carefully with a champagne glass
that's the thing it's not as white of a
brim for you to just chug it down all
right guys here we go
we're starting off with a group date and
it's a man pageant two mansions
I loved this date the guys strip down to
their speedos showed off their talents
it was super funny especially because I
thought this was some of the best guest
appearance thing we've seen in a while
I loved the drag queens and
miss J so much personality so many
wide-eyed moments they just really wowed
me but what did you guys think of this
date because the only thing I will say
is it's one of those moments on The
Bachelorette where I think if the roles
were reversed like the crowd was
cheering at one point a man doing that
to women on stage it's not a great look
I didn't love that it's like let's keep
the playing field nice and even where it
should be you know so Jed is a lot
buffer that maybe we knew so cheers to
that
mm-hmm just cheers to the guys and all
their physiques they all looked great
hmm did you have a favorite one you were
most attracted to eleven you on the top
a six-pack doesn't do it for me I like
nice strong arms and a lot of these guys
have some strong arms
but Jed goes from like super muscular to
super singer and he all of a sudden he's
like a jason morass like Fedora on where
did that come from
but man when he starts singing the look
on Hannah's face
she was just infatuated with him like
biting her lip loving it she was in full
beast mode the whole time and was proud
of her and I have to say Hanna Jie who
was hanabi's very good friend on Colton
season was here for roses and roses a
live and she said that we should really
watch Hannah's face this season because
she wears all of her emotions on her
face and when she smiles a certain way
you know she's into somebody when she
smiles like hey you know she's not she
was at the chat
Luke gets up on stage and his talent is
him telling Hannah that he's starting to
genuinely fall in love with her I'm
genuinely starting someone said that to
me after that about two conversations
with them like think about what your
reaction in the normal world would be a
bit and I have to leave now bye I'm
gonna take this drink thank you so much
for picking up the tab on the drinks
it's nice me okay now okay so I'm gonna
get an uber and then I'm gonna share my
status of my ride of my friends that
they know when I get home safely right
what does I'm starting to fall in love
with you mean you just throw the word
love in there and you get Miss J with
the wide eyes because they're all blown
away by it
but Luke P wins mr. right so I guess
there we are what I did appreciate was
that later at the cocktail party when
they're talking Hannah questions
Luke P and what he says it's so bad like
how do you know it scares me good job
Hannah cheers to Hannah for calling out
and you know who called him out a lot
Mike where's your crown a hat
Mike the hitch master I love Mike you
guys any straight-up tells him quote
you're a dog a dog yeah
yeah that took the breath from my body
Zanna says Luke takes her breath away
she said that's a night of buffets took
my breath away tonight so Mike just
calls Luke out for saying he's falling
in love with her says he doesn't believe
him says how do you know that and Luke
goes books that's phenomenal question
that's real question man that's a real
question I love Mike cheers for every
time Mike just slayed Mike is our
warrior mike is the audience's voice
here we like Mike
[Music]
then the date cart comes to the mansion
and I did not expect
touji to get the first one I want I
don't even remember meeting him on night
one I think I just thought he had really
piercing eyes like a little Twilight II
what did you guys think I'm Tyler
getting the first one-on-one surprising
understandable I was really shocked but
Hannah did bring a lot of guys who were
standouts on that first group date so
maybe she just wanted to get to know
more about Tyler yeah I wouldn't trade
it for anything I think I was probably
smiled by the entire time back to the
second half of the group date and Hannah
is talking to Jed and she mentions that
she likes his southern charm about she
combined with his openness you just all
different types of people and again
Hanna ji told me that we should watch
out for that because Hanna really wants
a guy with that classic modern though
southern charm I want to give this
phrase to you jacket Jed is notable and
then you know what Jed gets the rose Oh
Jed lost the battle the mr. right
pageant but he won the war he got the
rose and I think that's notable I'm also
still thinking about Game of Thrones Jed
plus the
Battle of winter for no but the battle
Thunder fellas the one for all of life
this still bothers me you guys the whole
season all right I'm sorry I back to the
Bachelorette it's a different kind of
Game of Thrones a game of rose okay
we're on the one-on-one with Tyler and
Tyler is giving me Jared vibes he
reminds me of Jared haben a little bit
like both looks-wise and he just seems
like a nice sweet guy that's the thing
about this date I didn't really have
much to say about it other than it seems
like a normal date they didn't get to
deep and personal but Tyler seems nice
and Hannah gave him a rose and that's
great what did you think of Tyler next
up we are on another group date and this
time it's roller derby the guys are not
skating no more flailing don't drink
every time one of them falls
[Music]
who all fallen all over the place
[Music]
smoker oles that's the battle losing the
battle one of the war what in the war is
one of the roads oh my god and then
Tyler said that he lost the battle but
the war is the rose honestly didn't I
just say that I had to just written I'd
written that done by Jen so cheers to
myself I'm a psychic it was so fun
watching Oliver mostly flailing body
says the guys weren't skating they were
flailing drink every time I'm a psychic
tonight
I'm sorry guys I have to talk about the
kisses because they zoom in on them so
much I mean the resolution on these
cameras I want to know how far away the
camera is while they're kissing that
they like get that close I just gotta
know that notice that Dustin had a
pretty serious stache and Anna seemed to
be like all up in the stache and I've
never kissed anyone with a moustache so
I can't speak to it please let me know
in the comments what's it like is it
okay are you kissing hair is it weird
you hear everyone talk about her and
talk about how great she is and
everything we're hearing from the guys
more we're getting to know them more and
we get some ITM moments with Garrett and
drink for every inch of hi Pat Garrett's
hair house it is like up here what
product is he using that's the first
question I'm gonna ask it when I meet up
is it a pomade is it a spray do you
blow-dry it is it a combination a little
bit like Roger from Doug vibes with the
hair but Garrett took a looking guy and
you know what I give a guy credit he
takes the time on his hair I really do I
really do feel like I need some time
this week
mr. so cam we've been seeing him all
episode he's been like cooped up in the
mansion not going out on dates remember
he met Hannah on the live AFR and he got
a kiss that night once oh camon kind of
already at his time but cam doesn't like
this cam doesn't like being cooped up so
cam has gone from a be seeing always
being camp to de effing dude exhibiting
ferocity shows up on the date and I Anna
like looks to the side as if she's
looking at the producers like doing
interact with him what do i do what's
happening and I guess he showed up the
doctor for 30 seconds and make out with
her whatever it's that time in the show
where everybody's gonna be upset about
time being stolen and blah blah blah um
there's also a guy in a red shirt who
looks like the other Tyler but I don't
think it's the other Tyler he got the
one-on-one I don't know who the red
shirt guy is try not to get over Hannah
litical over its overanalyze things but
cams talking to Hannah and making a lot
of puns about like analyzing things and
then cams talking to the cam and know
what her expectations are orders which
is a pun he should have made and oh my
god Tyler is slowly walking up behind
him like a horror movie ABC can actually
be careful
Tyler taps him on the back to call him
out for what he's done by showing up on
this date clearly and cams eyes are like
flooded with fear there's a lot of I
work on the state like Miss Jay
[Music]
then this moments interesting cam makes
his case with Tyler and we all signed up
for this knowing that this comes with
the territory
look man hey I want somebody bold she
doesn't want somebody passive he doesn't
want a passive man who did you guys
agree with cam or Tyler cam or Tyler I
see what cam is saying I do I'm not into
that thing where people like get mad
about people's time it's like do what
you got to do and be yourself because
truly there are no rules on this show
there's no rules just right where does
that phrase come from Mac Steakhouse no
rules just right I don't like that
phrase and then oh my god now Garrett
has come to talk to cam I couldn't
believe this I thought it would just be
a Tyler cam showdown drink for every guy
who couldn't friends cam but it's also
late guys abcdefgh I go Hannah interact
go talk to Hannah because you are not
gonna get this time back and you're
wasting your time
confronting cam a be seeing a lot of
boys confronting cam instead of talking
to Hannah this is all the time you have
forget it this is a mistake don't do it
then the red shirted guy he's gonna
confront cam and they have a weird
interaction about cam stepping on
people's toes and cam said y'all's toes
don't matter toes don't matter which I
just thought was funny coming back and
the red shirt guy like backing away
backing away back in a way drink for
every step backwards he takes mmm-hmm
both literally and in his relationship
with Hannah because he should just be
talking to Hannah you know I'm saying
all right so then we find out red shirts
name is Kevin his name is Kevin and he
says that he doesn't like cam
shenanigans and let's be honest he
should have had another pun and called
them [ __ ] cam against alcohol
[Applause]
I'll be honest Chris likes that I have
this outlet to get out my weirdness he's
like get the singing out at work that's
fair I didn't know who was gonna get the
rose and then Dustin got it and that was
a surprise to me but I guess it's like
when you get her and on a date you got
the rose I don't know and then Kevin
said he's just gonna make me really sad
if I get sent home because my name
starts to dissolve from her memory and
I'm sorry but I was a psychic again
because I didn't know Kevin's name it
didn't dissolve okay back at the mansion
for the cocktail party and a lot of
brunette dudes in grey suits which I
support I love a gray suit Hannah comes
in to the cocktail party and I don't
know why she's crying she's just crying
it's very unclear to me I don't want her
to cry I love her I want her to be
comforted but I don't know why I didn't
get a full understanding maybe just
tired she's probably tired and
overwhelmed come on if I still have feel
oh no no for sure
and then Kevin whose name we now know
steals Hannah and I love this he was
like let's just scream
I loved Kevin so much in this brief
amount of time he like said what his job
is he works for the army and he does
like behavioral counseling he called
said yes ma'am to her he had a fun
moment with her in like 30 seconds I
loved Kevin and then cam ruined it Oh
cam ABC always be coming around and then
I don't even know what happened he like
ruined their cute moment with a weird
threesome moment to sit them down on the
ground and eat chicken nuggets inside of
some rose petals it was so strange Oh
ABC always be chicken nugget Inc it was
weird right it was just killing the vibe
will you accept this honey mustard do
you guys agree where you over cam at
this point I kind of was so we've had
abcdefgh I now we have lMNO look man
open to the nuggets get out of here with
those actually bring them over to me I
will eat them but I don't know why you
did what you did cam I wasn't on board
and Kevin was neither cookie throw up I
love this show
have you ever thrown chicken nuggets at
someone no go on The Bachelor The
Bachelorette you could weirdly we keep
using cams floor rose and Tyler and
Hannah are sitting and talking in the
floor rows and like drink at the entire
time that Tyler tried to sit down in
that rose he was like okay okay I got a
great suit oh I'm gonna sit on the
ground I don't I don't want to run this
suit I kind of spent a lot of money out
of it okay you look great
Luke and Hannah luckily don't do the
floor rows but instead they do it looks
like a dining room table I don't know
they're sitting on that table and this
is now lMNO P Q R possibly quite racy
and this moment takes a turn and oh it
takes a turn I mean takes a shirt off
yes Luke's shirt gets taken off and
Hannah talks about how hanging out Luke
is cyrillic really and a hot so hot to
drink for every like Oh moment that
Hannah is like oh I like him and she's
like caught up in and in like Hannah is
super attracted to Luke that's what we
know here and that's important because
that physical attraction especially when
you don't get to spend that much time
with someone means something on the show
and can either be powerful or misleading
so we got a lot to watch here what do
you guys think of Hannah looks
connection okay so Hannah is st you
super turned up in this moment and then
as they're like massaging each other
Chad comes in
and I loved out dry Jed was he looks at
shortlist Luke and he's like yeah dude
it's not super appealing not super
appealing there but Hanna did seem upset
tell me what you guys started this
moment because I think of old people
Hanna would not have wanted Jed to walk
in on that moment she was the catalyst
to I don't know what to do and I think
it mattered to her that Jed saw that
like she didn't want him to you know get
upset about what she was doing
they let things get out of control you
got to go fix things with Jed girl yeah
okay so jet and Hanna do have this cute
conversation and he said something
really wise that I'm gonna remember he
said that being jealous and worrying
jealous are worried it's never paid off
one time in my life Jed I like you I
like it Jed who are you guys into the
most after this episode tell me both
like mentally and emotionally and
physically because we did see them all
pretty naked
tell me rose ceremony is finally
happening and I think we sent home
Connor and Darren and a good-looking guy
in a gray suit but I never knew his name
maybe you'll see my paradise and then
they do cheers and all my god cam cheers
- Hanna having his last name to my
future best friend
miss Hanna aiyaaa my last name cam stop
can that was quite presumptuous cam ABC
always be claiming that name I like my
last name Zima that's great I don't ever
want to give it up
but oh the night's not over with the
rose ceremony I guess Luke took a note
from cam and he's being bold and he just
comes into a place where he was onion
baked hid Hanna's ITM that's another
acronym we can't forget in the moment
just when they're just talking directly
to the camera I think you know what
allergy is like so Luke comes in and he
and Hannah talk and you can feel the
chemistry between them and he tells her
that everything he's saying is 100% real
the guy said he was starting to fall in
love with her yes it was really soon but
he promises it's genuine did you guys
believe Luke here's what I think I think
Luke believes Luke let's not forget that
this is the guy who introduced himself
to us by saying that he had a
conversation with God in the show and
I'm not saying there's anything wrong
with that
I just think he's someone who clearly
believes in like what we cannot see and
destiny and fate in a higher power in
love at first sight it seems love at
first
shirtless massage love at first growling
at each other from the top of real love
at first telling someone that you love
them during a contrived men drag race
competition so that was this episode we
did have a cute moment at the end where
Mateo ate a bunch of bugs but didn't
tell Hannah yet that he is a sperm donor
and her father to more than 100 children
when will that happen I'm excited for
that moment I dug it I really think
Hannah says what she's thinking and it
makes for such better television and
these guys all have a lot of personality
I'm so on board I'm really loving this
season
and one more shameless plug
I am on cameo please send me your cameo
request if you want you guys because I
love doing them I've gotten such fun
ones and they've been so fun for me like
it's just a great moment to be creative
ABC always be creative I gotta stop his
phrase got second my head I get back
okay love you guys so much
leave your thoughts in the comments
below hey bc all always bye
so I'm just loving the season of The
Bachelorette and it's just been an
amazing journey for me so far and I'm
really opening up and letting my walls
come down and these guys are making me
do you want to sing a song yes abcdefg
cam is Boldin so Luke peeks at my lap
QRS TUV but who is being genuine with
Hanabi ABCD efg bottom line whose most
crazy
[Music]